the January 6th committee has cemented
its place in the history books the
culmination of 18 months of work more
than one thousand witness testimonies
and more than a million pages of
evidence summarized in an
845-page report this is Uncharted
Territory before the United States for
the Department of Justice to actually
weigh whether or not to bring charges
against Donald Trump
the report details how then president
Donald Trump carried out a plan to
overturn the 2020 presidential election
result
from knowingly disseminating false
information to pressuring the vice
president members of Congress and local
and federal officials
he failed then summoned a mob of his
supporters to Washington and did nothing
to stop them as they attacked the
capital for more than three hours
committee members were unanimous in
their conclusion one man caused the
January 6th attack Donald Trump
and they've made clear he must be held
accountable earlier this week they
formally accused the former president of
inciting Insurrection and other crimes
and recommended he face criminal
prosecution
the justice department is conducting its
own investigation and the committee
hopes its findings will be a road map
for the special council heading that
process
Trump has dismissed what he says are
fake charges as an attempt to block his
White House run in two years time
analysts say it's a significant moment
for U.S politics this is unprecedented
we're talking about a former U.S
president and also a candidate for the
president of the United States in 2024
even though this is non-binding this
certainly puts pressure on the justice
department to actually weigh this
evidence against the former president
Republicans will take control of
Congress in the New Year almost
certainly putting an end to any further
Congressional investigations into the
Insurrection now ensuring accountability
for the attack and the decision to press
charges lies solely with the Department
of Justice
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera